when you are really behaving as a person
and doing things exactly as you would
and responding to an environment exactly
as you would in life
this is acting so simple it's very
difficult to allow yourself to be that
simple
can you explain how someone quieting
their mind can lead them to their life's
purpose
okay
quieting your mind or stealing Yourself
by breathing into your heart
is taking you to a place of being as
I've talked about it's taking to a still
space where you can just be
in that space you can ask yourself
questions this is the same space that
artists go to ask questions for
inspiration
so with an actor
you always you're always acting in a
place that's number one the environment
where where am I most of the time actors
are not moved by their environment at
all you know that doesn't matter to them
they're busy acting they're busy saying
the words
um but you know you are in an
environment and I train actors to touch
the chair to feel things and first of
all to make choices about where am I
where am I what makes it so
so if you're you know in class I'm in a
bedroom well what makes it so well I'm
going to bring these things it's my
bedroom so I'm going to bring my bedding
I'm going to bring just enough of my own
things my props and my personal
possessions to help me believe in this
space if you're an actor and you're on a
set and you can't bring those things you
go around the bedroom that's your
bedroom and you type this is my bed
which side do I sleep in what's in the
drawer you know I'm a pain in the Aslan
said I'm all over the plate this is my
thing I gotta claim it I have to believe
in it so the first thing is that space
so
it's you know you might ask the question
well where am I in this scene and then
it's obvious you know you're in your
bedroom yeah but where could I be
well you could be in the kitchen
well where else could I be I could be in
the garden
what if I was in the garden now
something lit up with you in the garden
well how would the garden work so it's
all a series of questions and then how
do I create a garden well I'm just going
to put three or four plants I'm going to
put this chair and then that's going to
be my garden what makes my garden well
what are you doing in the garden what
are you doing in the garden because it
doesn't come alive for an actor unless
he's doing something unless he brings it
into Behavior because the story is told
in Behavior
so I went on that little detour to say
that's where you ask questions from is
that space so when you steal yourself
and you breathe into your heart and you
ask yourself you know
what do I want to do in life why am I
here what is my purpose in that
Stillness
something can come in whether it's
inspiration to answer a question you're
posing as an artist or whether it's
inspiration your higher self to help you
along the way to knowing what it is you
want to do and what your purpose in life
is
I think you had used an example in the
book of a gentleman who had turned 50.
and he was a police officer and he
realized this was his what he felt was
his one chance to become an actor so you
had him create his space in the locker
room get his environment that you know
this uh environment exercise which I
I've been writing about for years and
years and years but it is the most
powerful thing because with actors you
don't give them words at first they only
have two things they create an
environment and then they do the things
they really do in that environment so
first they have to observe their life so
this is the training always begins with
observing so they observe their life for
their life's rhythms so this guy came to
me and you know I interview every
student
mostly for attitude it's all about
attitude because you know I'm I'm old
and I don't want anybody with my crappy
attitude that I had when I was either an
actor so I want people with happy
attitudes and to create a you know very
uh a group that reflects all of humanity
all ages all colors all Sexes you know I
like it even even amount of men and
women and such so this guy came to me
and I was interviewing him and he said
uh he said he wanted to be an actor and
you know he he always wanted to be an
apple actor but he thought it was a pipe
dream and so he kept putting it away I'd
do the right thing he became cop but now
it was 15 I thought I'm never going to
get to do it I I want to do it and I
don't know how he found me but that's
the universe always kind of puts those
connections together so he found me and
I went oh okay so I wanted to check on
his uh commitment
so I said uh are you a good cop
and he said yeah I'm a great cop I go oh
yeah what makes you a great cop because
I care I really care
I go excellent
can you give that same commitment to
acting in my class
he said yeah
I said okay you can come to class now
this guy is a beginner beginner
and he's coming to class with people who
are currently shooting series I put them
all in the same class it's all attitude
and he did his first exercise in the
first exercise the environment exercise
to create a place right
so first he observed he observed himself
in his locker room to the police station
and he observed every detail of his
behavior and he noted that and he
rehearsed that without the locker room
so he could figure out how he was going
to create or lock a room on stage in the
theater and then he created this locker
room
and he did those behaviors ex with the
same investment it's different though
because now he's consciously doing them
he said he did things inevitably actors
discover this in observing his own
behavior he discovered that he did
things he never knew that he did and
just did them automatically now he's
doing them consciously and he's really
investing in the behavior he's really
doing it consciously exactly as he does
it
in life that brings an actor to the now
that brings him to the present moment
just doing and believing in that space
without words without emotions without
any story just being and doing that's
like this this is the first two steps
this guy did this exercise and he
was he was about to leave the exercise
it was almost finished and he had a
thought he went to his locker room we
saw when he was just a box but he opened
up the box and had a picture of a guy on
the thing which was a buddy who had died
in service and he had a second thought
and he put He undid his jacket and he
put on a bulletproof vest and he put his
jacket back on and he looked at the guy
very simple and he left the scene I was
saying they exercised I could have put a
camera on this this is the guy's first
time ever on a stage in his life he
didn't even do little plays as a child
this is his first time ever
and uh he was beautiful he was just a
person when you are really behaving as a
person and doing things exactly as you
would and responding to an environment
exactly as you would in life
this is acting so simple it's very
difficult to allow yourself to be that
simple